welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of ms
marvel episode 5 which further breaks
the mcu's already broken time travel
logic but does so in the most beautiful
way while doing to the clandestines what
would happen to me if i ever try to
leave this blue dungeon
i am going to explain exactly what
happened this episode some interesting
easter eggs that you might have missed
into some really cool visual details
reminder that the best way to support
new rockstars is with our miss marvel
inspired shirt cosmic daydream which
gives you the option to write in a
custom shout out for our after show
newrockstarsmerch.com this episode opens
with a song called tomara chand by
soraya and shiam from the 1949 bollywood
film dilaggi which itself was an
adaptation of the 1939 film wuthering
heights the story of a tragic romance of
lovers kathy and heathcliff who are
forced apart by circumstance kathy first
appears as a ghost before her story is
told via flashback just as this episode
flashed back on characters thought to be
ghostly gin catching up to their tragic
parting of ways actually the song to
merit sean's words translate to you are
my moon i am your moonlight which if you
think about it is a variation on what
you seek is seeking you kamala herself
being the light that she seeks in fact
really the phrase what you seek is
seeking you is a way to describe how all
of us are on predestined paths that
loved ones and things that you seek out
are also on a distant path to find their
way to you the marvel studios title
imagery transitions to a sepia-toned
grainy film stock that skips in a 4x3
letterbox aspect ratio as this becomes a
1940s newsreel explaining the partition
with the newly appointed indian prime
minister jawaharlal nehru and we see
pakistan's political founder muhammad
ali jinnah a mural of whom appeared in
karachi last episode we see a map
showing india and pakistan dividing with
territory to the rest of india
demarcated for pakistan but also a
section to the east this would go on to
become bangladesh but initially at the
start of the partition bengal's assembly
voted to be part of pakistan that is
until 1971 when war broke out and
bangladesh secured its independence as a
separate country from pakistan we also
see mahatma gandhi the indian freedom
fighter arguably most influential in
india's independence from british rule
who was assassinated a year after this
in 1948. this episode then jumps back to
1942 which was really the year gandhi
first openly formally began pushing for
the british to just completely leave
india aisha flees a british soldier
after leaving the ruins of where they
found the bengal that was marked with
the ten rings logo back in episode three
we intercut from her bare feet to his
boots and then she flings an ornate
dagger at him presumably this is her
clandestine weapon as they all can
summon weapons but it aligns aisha more
with the red dagger society last episode
the ms marvel titles flickered between
english and urdu now we only have one
english one shown on a torn british flag
but the rest are in various languages
there's urdu hindi gujarati punjabi
bengali tamil and telugu actually last
week there was one in the colors of the
1992 pakistan qriket national team so
it's just kind of fun to go through
these one by one so let's do it after
the union jack there's one in urdu
showing the shadows of muslim refugees
on a wall with bullet holes in it then
one in hindi showing a field of flowers
then another one in urdu showing the
mural of the red daggers and you see
there is one male and one female then
there's another one in urdu showing a
photograph of refugees then another in
hindi on a blue train car marked with
nwr india's northwestern state railway
hinting at the trains that they have to
take out of india then in assamese or
bengali in smoke by the train tracks
then one in hindi over a map showing the
border between india and pakistan then
another in assamese or bengali then an
interesting one a cracked border in
concrete on one side urdu on the lower
side hindi a literal partition between
urdu and hindi matching the border
between pakistan and india then one in
tulugu actually in a stylish font of
kanada over a field of roses like
hassan's rose garden overlooking a city
in the mist maybe a hint at the nor
dimension then one in punjabi stamped on
a resettlement card for the khan family
one man one woman one infant
registration office 4291 index number
12. cards like these were assigned to
migrant muslim families then one in
gujarati on a tapestry then another in
punjabi over a parody of the vintage
universal pictures logo reading marvel
studios presents and a sloth baby
production and that of course is
kamala's youtube channel then one in
tamil over a depiction of refugees then
another in gujarati purple text on a
cosmic background and then one final one
in urdu green over roses in hassan's
village a few kids are playing cricket
women purchase some bracelets and hassan
stirs up the crowd citing mahatma gandhi
to resist being forced off their land
the british soldiers break up the crowd
aisha naps and hassan's rose garden
roses being very important to the
language and culture and the general
lore of the country of pakistan inside
hassan says you know when i saw you out
there
it reminded me of my favorite poem
when the soul lies down in that grass
the world is too full to talk about
what you seek
is seeking you yes he's quoting rumi a
13th century persian poet a sufi mystic
and a major influence on the entire
muslim world aisha is smitten and
reveals her name my name is aisha
aisha
she who lives
a beautiful man yes she who lives
ironically dies this episode some time
passes and aisha gets hassan with a new
walking stick as she sports one of the
roses in her hair looking a lot like
sana's painting of her that we saw last
episode they both rest their hands on
her baby bump as the bangle is framed
right beside it symbolizing how this
bangle will pass down through the women
of this lineage aisha sings an urdu
lullaby and has a division between the
muslims and the hindus grow wider najma
finds aisha and gives her until sundown
to retrieve the bengals so that they can
go back to their home dimension so aisha
gets the family to flee to the train
station but hassan confronts her who's
that woman you're talking to last night
yeah notice the music mixes in that
menacing sting that's always been used
to introduce the threat of nachman
i've been waiting a very long time to
meet you aisha shows him the bengal and
writing appears on the cuff's outer
bands this is the inscription that she
added that walid noticed later quoting
hassan's recitation of rumi's poem now
since the clandestine can transfigure
their token weapons this tells us that
she has turned to the protective bangle
as her token unfortunately najma still
has her weapon and aisha without any
protection gets stabbed in the stomach
as najib walks off aisha warns her it
won't work huh so what does aisha know
about the death trap of traveling
through the veil of nor that notchmen
does not or at least does not want to
believe aisha may be more privy to the
terms of their banishment and or more at
peace with their exile saying goodbye to
high interest credit card debt is one of
the first steps toward financial
independence but the interest month
after month can feel like you're in a
never-ending hamster wheel that's where
upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple and easy to understand payment
terms upstart has helped over 1.8
million customers on their path to
financial freedom whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses upstart can help you get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows that you are
more than just your credit scores so
rather than looking at your credit score
alone upstart's model considers other
factors like your income your employment
and other information provided in your
loan application to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate in minutes for loans between 1 000
and 50 000 without impacting your credit
score you can even receive funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan so don't wait and check your rate
today at upstart.com new rockstars
that's upstart.com new rockstars to
check your rate today don't forget to
use our url to let them know that we
sent you go to upstart.com new rockstars
aisha's life drains from her
and the bengal glows as do aisha's eyes
and this either coincides with or
causally triggers kamala's arrival
through the rift in time opened up by
the bengal from the present day last
episode yes this episode confirms that
kamala actually traveled back in time
and it was she who cast the trail of
stars that saved her own grandmother now
this type of time travel is referred to
as a closed loop or predestination
wherein unexplained anomalies from the
past are later revealed to be the effect
of present characters looping back to
the past events to set the timeline the
way it has always been it's actually one
of the more common tropes in time travel
fiction you may know it from prisoner of
azkaban where a mysterious patronus that
saves harry potter was actually cast by
himself looping back to the past or from
terminator where the human resistance
leader john connor was conceived by the
same protector went back in time to save
his mother or christopher nolan's
interstellar or tenet where bizarre
phenomena happened early on in the movie
and are later revealed to be the same
heroes looping back on themselves
filmmakers will often default to this
because these twists do pack some
narrative catharsis suggesting that the
chaos of the world is actually part of a
divine plan but it also implies
characters have no free will since for
their lives to even exist they must make
the choice of time travel that choice
has really been made for them now you
may feel this violates the mcu's time
travel logic from avengers in-game which
suggested traveling back in time doesn't
cause you to live within the past as it
was but rather form a new branch
timeline a separate reality however
endgame's own ending contradicts that
logic with the confusing arrival of old
steve rogers the screenwriters claim old
cap lived in the background of the mcu
as we've known it which violates their
own branch timeline logic meanwhile the
directors maintain old cap must have
traveled back to this timeline from a
different reality ultimately folks the
narrative priority with that final scene
was not logic it was really emotional
catharsis but then we got loki which
gave us a lot of new rules of how time
travel works in the mcu but that series
ended by suggesting that all the events
of the mcu were part of he who remains
predestined script the sacred timeline
and that includes even the eventuality
that the sacred timeline would unravel
into infinite branches the gambit he
remains opposed to loki and sylvie was
really a false choice he knew that
sylvie would stab him and that the
timeline would rupture into a multiverse
he wanted that to happen that was part
of his plan now he who remains monologue
and loki's finale do remain up for
interpretation but one conclusion we can
all agree on is that marvel studios sees
themselves as master clock makers and
their universe as a pre-destined road
map a timeline engineered in universe by
manipulators like kang in specific ways
that we're about to learn a lot more
about so this seeming accident of kamala
connecting with a great grandmother
through these bengals through time was
pre-ordained and designed by
someone and if you look closely at those
branching timelines around the citadel
in the loki finale many of them do
intersect with each other and bend
backwards upon themselves each
intersection may represent an incursion
multiverse of madness showed us what an
incursion looks like when universes
collide walid shows us what an incursion
looks like when realms collide and now
we are seeing what an incursion looks
like when timelines collide now aisha
does say here anger worked
salah
it brought you back to me
i'm not son yeah see aisha did not think
she was opening a rift in time to summon
her great granddaughter from the future
she just wanted the bengal to save her
daughter sanna so from that i think we
conclude it was not najma stabbing the
bangle in the present that opened a rift
and it wasn't aisha's sort of prayer
that opened the rift from the past
according to loki causality is
incidental no matter what these points
in the timeline were going to intersect
and history here just justified itself
with the stimuli to trigger it
internally in this instance it was a
piece of cree tech or some other alien
tech mixed with clandestine nor magic to
tear this rift into reality the walls of
which have already been weakening from
all these things that have been
happening in the mcu theoretically this
origin could have been scripted out by
kang or one of the kangs to produce a
clandestine descendant armed with cree
tech to join the pantheon of marvel
heroes in his eventual master plan to
stage a secret wars event or maybe buy
some other kang to produce a friend for
kang's alternate self of nathaniel
richard's iron lad in a young avengers
lineup there's a lot of ways we can read
this but hey welcome to phase four folks
time travel none of this makes sense so
yes kamala creates a nor platform to
create a path for sana but then she gets
knocked by someone and the platform
dissipates but stays in this star form
that is controlled by sana herself
guiding herself back to hassan she was
able to do this because she had some nor
magic in her blood and had the bangle so
in a sense one bangle was reunited with
another bangle just the same one through
time however we gotta remember there is
another bangle one for the right hand
that exists somewhere hidden in this
world i am assuming among the collection
of dane whitman's uncle nathan so kamala
returns to the present where the veil of
nor rift has opened it glows from golden
to teal color to fuchsia and it widens
and widens as faria reaches into it she
turns into a statue of what this
episode's audio description refers to as
quote black crystalline rock which then
crumbles to reveal her skeleton and yes
this transformation does resemble the
way terogenesis is shown in agents of
shield terrigen mist forms a rocky
cocoon around a person and then they
emerge from that cocoon as an inhuman
with powers in the clandestine's case
clearly not but a similar aesthetic is
at least worth noting maybe terogenesis
will be revealed in the series as a
worthiness judgment in the nor realm
like what we saw in the duat realm in
moon knight with the scales of anubis
like in this case as you pass through
the veil if your heart is impure you
emerge from that cocoon dead but if your
heart is pure like maybe if aisha or
kamala were to try to pass through this
veil they'd emerge from that cocoon
transformed or i don't know maybe they
just wanted to show how the veil of
nora's energy differential melts you
into bones like the wrath of god in
indiana jones but disney made them put
up this goofy vanity curtain to spare
viewers from the gorier details so then
najma offers herself to the veiled
portal and suddenly feeling bad for
leaving cameron behind utters his name
and transfers her nor light through the
veil killing herself but the way aisha's
nor light summoned her descendant
through time or maybe it was just a
random coincidence because of gang yeah
i know we talked about that najma's nor
light redirects to kamran giving him the
same ambiguon nor light that kamala has
except more teal colored and apparently
able to be controlled without the use of
a bangle so in the comics kamran isn't
inhuman the way kamala is he's just hit
with the same territory miss that kamala
is exposed to and it gives him different
powers than stretchy limbs he has blue
colored inner bioluminescence
look folks i am just doing my best to
explain what the hell happened here the
logic of the clandestines on the show is
largely unexplained i'm not a writer on
the show this is all super inconsistent
with j-willow wilson's comics so uh
light is magic and can be transferred
among descendants of extra-dimensional
beings amplified by aliatec that's
connected to the ten rings i guess
marvel studios it's just pterogenophobic
and they will throw literally anything
from marvel or against the walloping
youtube will make sense of it for them
which uh yeah yeah you got us hook line
and sinker but i always do love the use
of light and color on this show and i
love how the alleyway and lighting that
accompanied comrade for pretty much the
rest of this episode are that same blue
hue that his inhuman form is in the
comics but kamala proves that her trip
to the past was not just a dream or a
vision she brought back with her a
physical item the way hawkeye brought
back a baseball glove to the present as
proof here the photograph actually
parallels pixar's coco the wayward child
meeting their ancestor and returning
with a family photo to heal the
generational divide within their living
relatives korean tells kamala although
the us government may or may not have
several warrants out from my arrest u.s
government this guy's a pakistani
citizen it just sounds like the red
dagger's vigilantism has gotten the
attention of us agencies like the dodc
and may set up kareem to return in
titles like the thunderbolts yeah
yeah i'll be fine he could be another
one of val's recruits where i'm sure
kareem will just have to deal with quite
a few racist microaggressions from john
walker but kareem gives kamala his red
scarf remember last episode waleed gave
kamala this blue vest sana gave her the
bengal bruno gave her the mask and i
guess she provided her own red shoes
that the mosque's thief let her keep
really we're seeing all the components
of her final form contributed to her by
different influences within her
community and now the final piece of it
moniva finds her golden necklace that
previously showed kamala's name in urdu
but now bent to form her swishy bolt
logo i assume next episode of aniva will
complete the arc of the unused hulk
outfit and create kamala's final
superhero look and kamala will actually
be a good daughter and wear it in the
scrapbook that they look at are some old
photos of aniva and some ticket stubs
from concerts you went to one reading
bruce presumably for bruce springsteen
whom sonic calls through springfield
before moniva corrects her to bon jovi
and then there's a blue ticket stub but
the blue ticket stub was for a show at
the oakland coliseum telling us that
moniba spent some time in the bay area
kamala says
why have i never heard of this which is
what boniba asked earlier about the find
my phone feature then why am i only just
hearing about this yes the mother and
daughter are more alike than they
realize cameron finds bruno in the alley
this interaction witnessed by a closed
circuit security camera presumably the
dodc was using the government facial
recognition software we know shield uses
to track loki in the 2012 avengers that
must be how they attract cameron to this
location comrade doesn't really get
bruno's argon science joke poster this
is exactly the kind of nerd humor that
peter parker wears on his shirts actor
matt lintz actually auditioned to play
the mcu peter parker before the role
went to tom holland like every scene i
watched this guy and i'm like yeah he
could have been a pretty great peter
parker cameron also doesn't know who the
inventor nikola tesla is he assumes it's
just supposed for tesla cars then one of
the dodc drones retrofitted from the
start drones from far from home appear
outside the window and camaron uses his
nor to swat it away blasting out the
window glass but bruno's jochkes are
still standing the drone retaliates by
completely leveling the circle q shock
between this and del mar's deli and
queens that we saw in spider-man
homecoming the boutiques of the new york
area are under attack and we must
protect them at all costs so now with
the bland destined toast and the veil of
noor closed it seems like the final
conflict of the finale will be with
agent dever in the dodc and sure maybe a
trigger happy racial profiling
government agency will be enough
especially with this agency returning
shield and maybe secret invasion but
remember it is still a mystery where the
bengal came from and how it is connected
with the ten rings so we may learn more
about diver and cleary's connections to
a broader conflict with the cree out of
the marvels and of course i think carol
danvers owes us just a little cameo
that's everything i spot in this episode
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at
lost following rock stars subscribe to
rockstar someone else's everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you